Rainbow six siege has just received the
third of its for Plan B 1 dlc packs
operation scale rain the Brazilian theme
DLC adds two new operators attacker
Kappa Tau and defender kuvira a new map
favela that features exterior shell
destruction a tactical realism custom
game mode as well as a bunch of minor
fixes I spent pretty much a full day
diving into the new content so let me
give you the rundown on what I found the
new favela map like all previously
released maps is free for all players
much has been made of the new exterior
shell destruction which allows players
to blow out exterior walls to minimize
hiding places for the opposing team
these walls are all destructible by all
the usual means sledge ash thermite
breaching charges and good old elbow
grease the objective sights on favela
have plenty of destructible walls so
camping in an unreinforced corner isn't
the best idea roaming seems to be the
way to go for this map as it's easy to
get the drop on your opponents in the
maze like layout speaking of getting the
drop on opponents the first new operator
kuvira is a dynamo for roaming and
sneaking her first unique ability is
silent step that allows her to get up
close without alerting enemies in order
to incapacitate and interrogate them
revealing enemy positions on the map
when using silent step Guevera is
restricted to a sidearm Louis son a
non-lethal pistol with a built-in
silencer I'm garbage with side arms
which is why I never play shield
operators so I never really used silent
step to its full potential that being
said in the right hands being able to
down enemies and then interrogate them
will be invaluable and when paired with
frost swell compatibility interrogation
is going to be an absolute beast as it
stands now I'm not sure where I sit on
the interrogation ability I've always
liked the tagging enemies with drones
and cameras gives you a static position
marker that doesn't follow the enemy but
interrogation marks enemies with their
operators symbol and it follows them for
about 10 seconds it's kind of like when
it defender ventures outside part of me
feels that 10 seconds is too long while
the other things that it's a worthy
reward for the risk of exposing yourself
for the time it takes to execute the
interrogation it's going to be
interesting to see how the community and
players far above my skill level and
double using Povera the second new
operator is the attacker capital his
unique ability is a micro crossbow that
fires two different kinds of ammunition
the first a micro smoke grenades that
can be deployed to cover your advance
well the second area of effect is
fixating bolts basically they're flaming
arrows to burn off the oxygen in a small
area damaging enemies in close proximity
they're grateful when you need to keep
an enemy from advancing
when you want to flush someone out of a
hiding place you can't quite get an
angle on hot tip no pun intended
asphyxiating bolts are deadly to Kappa
Tau so don't make the same mistake I did
by firing them into the wall in front of
you the micro smoke grenades I found
useful at least in theory as
misdirection I tried to fly them over
the head of enemies to try and make it
seemed we were entering from a different
direction but like every round of siege
I've ever played my best laid plans
would go out the window as soon as I
encountered even the slightest hitch
usually in the form of someone shooting
me in the head unfortunately I wasn't
able to get enough people together to be
able to try the tactical realism mode
but it looks like everything I'm looking
for and more the hardcore modes goal is
to increase immersion by reducing
reliance on in-game feedback staples
like crosshairs enemy marking friendly
fire markers and kill confirmations are
all gone and there's new more realistic
magazine management there have also been
a host of tweaks and changes to the
underlying game the Ubisoft is referring
to as the health program one of the
major updates is in your attachment the
angled grip that allows faster aiming
down sights don't worry it's not call of
duty level of snappiness but I did find
it useful when I needed to draw on an
enemy in a 1v1 situation the downside is
an increased recoil so using this with
sustained fire isn't ideal but as a
burst grip for players new to siege who
may grapple with the slower pacing or
seasoned vets who like to roam around
the map it's a great addition another
handy new feature is the ability to
check what loadouts your teammates have
selected during the ready up phase a few
times I noticed we were all loading in
with barbed wire or frags so I would
back out and adjust my loadout
accordingly I also used it to check the
load out of skilled players that was
match made with so I could see how their
gear differed customizing gear is now
much prettier thanks to a full screen
weapon preview that can be zoomed to
highlight specific attachments the
tactical map has also been improved with
more detail for both defenders and
attackers the heads-up display has also
been updated with armor no longer
displayed and you player icons that
according to OB soft make determining
the status of your teammates are much
smoother process during play however I
found them you ? player indicators
harder to read the red X that denotes a
dead player has been dimmed so at a
glance it's harder to quickly identify
how many enemies are still kicking
around maybe it's just a transitional
thing I'll adjust to in time but I'd
suggest a brighter red X to make info
like this more easily read at a glance
overall operation scale rain is a
welcome improvement to an already great
lying game the addition of the two new
operators is exciting and I can't wait
to see how they end up being used in
higher skilled play the amount of
destruction on favela makes for a more
dynamic changing map that asks players
to adjust their play style and the
worker be soft is put into improving the
base game for the health program will
help maintain an audience of tactical
multiplayer shooter fans if you want to
talk Rainbow six or just video games in
general come find me on Twitter and for
a full list of the other tweaks and
changes they've been rolled out to siege
check out our coverage on gamespot